hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how to read
your cholesterol okay so what's the
function of cholesterol well it acts as
a cell membrane coding so every single
cell in the body every single cell has a
coating of cholesterol so we need that
all the outside of your skin has a
cholesterol layer cholesterol is needed
to make hormones specifically stress
hormones in certain other hormones for
anti-inflammation also it's involved in
brain activity and so when you don't
have enough cholesterol it can affect
your memory and that's why one of the
side effects of statin drugs which lower
the cholesterol is memory loss okay
there's many other functions but those
are the top three big functions okay
cholesterol is also needed to make
vitamin D it's also needed to make bile
B il e to actually help you dissolve
fats now what's funny to me is that you
know we talk about good and bad
cholesterol like HDL is called good
cholesterol you can kind of think of the
H is like a healthy cholesterol and then
LDL is supposed to the bad cholesterol
like if there's two types of cholesterol
but there's really no such thing as two
different types of cholesterol it's
really one cholesterol that's inside of
both of these little guys this stands
for high density lipoproteins okay this
is low-density lipoproteins do you
notice I didn't say cholesterol in order
to transport cholesterol which it
doesn't mix well with water or blood you
have to put it in a protein capsule and
that's what these are these are little
tiny shuttles that deliver cholesterol
in certain directions in the body so
let's talk about like let's talk about
the LDL first so we have this outer
covering of this protein okay that
surrounds the cholesterol and the
purpose of the LDL is to transport the
cholesterol from your gut and liver to
your intestinal tract and then write to
the blood so basically LDL takes the
cholesterol from the liver
in the blood and then from the blood it
goes to the rest of the tissues okay
that's what LDL does now HDL takes the
excess cholesterol that the LDL put in
there and removes it and brings it back
to the liver and then the liver can
actually dismantle it and take care of
it so basically we have this exchange
between cholesterol coming out of the
liver right here and cholesterol going
into the liver and we need that balance
so when you see that you have high
levels of bad cholesterol
you know doctors instantly give you a
drug to shut it down but what I want to
do is I'm going to teach you what's
behind that like what's causing that
problem we want to use this as a little
indicator light to tell us that there's
some problem inside a body normally the
LDL should be below 130 now in 2004 a
group of 15 doctors panels of doctors
that basically decided to lower the LDL
to 102 even as low as 70 for certain
people that are risk factors okay so
what they did is they adjusted the
numbers they changed the normal values
and put 8 million people on cholesterol
medication overnight that's what they
did well then we find out and I put a
link down there that a lot of these
doctors had ties to the drug companies
yeah I know surprise right so
unfortunately people are freaked out
about if that LDL is too high and so
we'll get more into that but basically
that's what it does so LDL takes the
cholesterol and drives it into the the
blood and then out to the tissues and
then HDL takes the excess cleans it up
and puts it back into the liver a normal
HDL is in a male body should be at 40 or
greater okay and a female body at 47 or
greater now let's talk first about let's
talk about triglycerides for a second
what is triglycerides those basically
those are blood fats
and basic 5 glycerides are converted
sugars okay so triglycerides are used to
transport excess carbohydrates so if you
have high triglycerides I know for a
fact you have too much sugar in your
body because the hormone insulin is the
converting hormone that makes
triglycerides high so we want about 150
or less that's the value petrol
glyceride so we don't want them greater
than 150 it's very easy to get to change
this and it's simply by getting rid of
sugar out of the diet now they also
talked about total cholesterol to HDL
ratios and all these different
calculations I don't like that I like
the triglyceride to HDL ratio the best
this will give the best indicator of
your risk for heart disease and
basically you just divide your total
cholesterol by I'm sorry total
triglycerides by the HDL and that gives
you the ratio and if it's greater than 6
there's a problem if it's 2 or less it's
good so we want it to be lower okay so
that's kind of a ratio you can look at
but really in reality there's really no
such thing as good or bad cholesterol it
just because you need cholesterol you
cannot live without cholesterol you just
want the exchange there I would say
about 99.99% of the time just by
cleaning up the sugar the carbs the
bread the pasta the alcohol you can
clean this up so fast and bring it back
to normal ranges ok there are genetic
cholesterol issues but it's very rare
it's not as common as you think but if
you do have a genetic tendency to have
high cholesterol even if you had 350
this studies showed that there's still
no risk for heart disease so the so for
them to put you on statins right away is
a big mistake because there's no study
that shows that it's actually going to
create a problem for you
especially if these other things are
working fine in fact I never ever look
at total cholesterol as anything I
ignore the total cholesterol and because
they did drop that down to 200 used to
be like 225 but even if it's like 350 if
it's less than 350 I'm not going to
worry about if these other things are
working fine and it's very rare for it
to go up if you're off sugars usually
it'll come right down the other point I
want to make is that 75% of the
cholesterol in your body right now is
made by your own body it's made by your
liver and the cells you liver makes
2,000 milligrams of cholesterol every
single day and the rest of the cells
make a thousand milligrams and only 25%
of the cholesterol in your body comes
from diet okay the rest comes from your
body making it so that might shift your
viewpoint because if you eat less your
body makes more if you eat more your
body makes less because we have this
feedback mechanism so I just want to
kind of cover some of these basics and
kind of give you the simplicity of what
it is so you're not freaked out about it
but for people to be put on medication
when they should be working like this is
what most people do if it's high they go
in a low-fat diet it's usually high
carbs they go on medication to go and
exercise that they never cut out the
sugar okay all right so go ahead and
apply this information make it put your
comments below thanks for watching